FROM NEW YORK CITY.
HAVE A GREAT NIGHT.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: HI, WELCOME TO THIS
BUSY NEWS BREAKING ADDITION
REPORTING FROM CALIFORNIA.
WERE ON THE WEST COAST AND
TONIGHT WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS ON
MULTIPLE FRONTS.
AT MOMENTS, LINDSEY GRAHAM WILL
JOIN US TO RESPOND TO
SUSAN RICE, CALLING HIM A PIECE
OF THE DASH.
WE START IN THE WASHINGTON SWAMP
WHERE HOUSE REPUBLICANS ARE
TODAY FIGHTING BACK AGAINST THIS
CORRUPT, SECRET BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS, SMOKE-FILLED ROOM, THE
IMPEACHMENT COUP ATTEMPTS.
HOURS AGO, A GROUP OF LAWMAKERS
LITERALLY STORMED INTO YET
ANOTHER TOP-SECRET SESSION OF
THE CORRUPT ADAM SCHIFF'S
KANGAROO COURT.
ONCE AGAIN THE COWARDLY CORRUPT
SCHIFF, THE LONG ADAM SCHIFF, HE
WAS SAID TO HOLD ANOTHER SECRET
IMPEACHMENT HEARING WITH SECRET
TESTIMONY RECORDED ONLY BY HIS
SECRET TRANSCRIPT.
REPUBLICANS CAN'T SEE IT UNLESS
THEY WERE DEMOCRATIC MINDER.
THE CORRUPT SCHIFF HALT OF THE
SESSION WHEN REPUBLICAN
LAWMAKERS ENTERED THE ROOM.
LET THIS BE A VERY CLEAR WARNING
TO SCHIFF AND PELOSI AND
DEMOCRATS EVERYWHERE, THE SECRET
SOVIET STYLE IMPEACHMENT
ATTEMPT, THIS CANNOT STAND.
WE HAVE A CONSTITUTION.
WE DO HAVE PRESIDENTS.
WE DO HAVE SOMETHING CALLED DUE
PROCESS.
REPUBLICANS WHO VALUE THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE SOVEREIGNTY
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THIS IS
A FIGHT WORTH FIGHTING.
AN INJUSTICE WORTH OVERTURNING.
BY THE WAY, EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY, EVERY ROOM IN THE U.S.
CAPITOL, REPUBLICANS OUGHT TO
HAVE A RIGHT TO BE THERE.
THE PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY HAVE A
RIGHT TO BE THERE.
THAT IS WHY IT'S A LEGITIMATE
END.
THEY RIGHTLY DEMANDING
TRANSPARENCY, DUE PROCESS, BASIC
FAIRNESS, EQUAL JUSTICE, AND IN
ANSWER TO A VERY SIMPLE QUESTION
ANSWER TO A VERY SIMPLE QUESTIO
QUESTION.
WHAT DOES THE CORRUPT
ADAM SCHIFF HAVE TO HIDE?
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT IS ADAM SCHIFF TRYING TO
HIDE?
THAT'S A QUESTION SO MANY PEOPLE
HAVE, SO MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE HAD SO MANY PEOPLE OF THE
PRESS SHOULD HAVE.
IN THOSE HIDDEN CLOSED DOORS
OVER THERE, ADAM SCHIFF IS
TRYING TO IMPEACH A PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES.
VOTING MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ARE
BEING DENIED ACCESS FROM BEING
ABLE TO SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING
BEHIND THESE CLOSED DOORS.
>> Sean: IT'S OBVIOUS FOR
ADAM SCHIFF, HE DOESN'T WANT YOU
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO KNOW THE
WHOLE TRUTH.
HE DOESN'T WANT YOU TO WATCH
THIS KANGAROO COURT PROCESS.
I THINK CAN BE FURTHER FROM THE
TRUTH WHEN HE SAYS WE WANT TO BE
TRANSPARENT.
THIS SO-CALLED IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY IS ONE BIG CORRUPT HOAX.
ONE BIG MASSIVE LIVE.
BY THE WAY, COMING UP TONIGHT,
LAWMAKERS WHO DID IN FACT TAKE
THE RIGHT STEP AND STORM HIS
TOP-SECRET SESSION, THEY WILL
JOIN US WITH MORE DETAILS.
LET'S BE CLEAR AND WE'VE SET IT
A MILLION TIMES AND I'LL SAY IT
AGAIN, CONGRESSMAN ADAM SCHIFF
IS NOT TRUSTWORTHY.
WE KNOW HE IS A PATHOLOGICAL
LIAR.
HE LIED ABOUT HAVING TOP-SECRET
EVIDENCE ON THE TRUMPET RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
HE PROMISED THAT TO US FOR TWO
YEARS.
HE LIED WHEN HE SAID THAT
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION WAS RIGHT
THERE IN PLAIN SIGHT.
NO IT WASN'T.
HE LIED ABOUT NOT HAVING ANY
PRIOR CONTACT WITH THE
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER, HEARSAY
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
WE KNOW NOW THAT HIS OFFICE IN
FACT HAD CONTACT WITH THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER AND WE BELIEVED
WAS GIVEN ADVICE FROM HIS
OFFICE.
THAT WOULD MAKE HIM AN PEOPLE IN
HIS OFFICE INTERIOR WITNESSES IN
THIS CASE.
IT DOESN'T GET ANY MORE CORRUPT
AND THAT IS THE REAL REASON THAT
HE DOESN'T WANT THIS
WHISTLE-BLOWER TO TESTIFY.
IF THAT HAPPENED HE WOULD LIKELY
BE EXPOSED AS HAVING BEEN A PART
OF THIS HOLE, ENTIRE SET UP.
BY THE WAY LET'S NOT FORGET ONE
OTHER THING
, BIG LIE ADAM SCHIFF, HE LIED
ABOUT THE TRANSCRIPT OF TRUMP'S
PHONE CALL WITH UKRAINE.
IN FACT, THAT GUY, THE CORRUPT
SCHIFF RIGHT A COMPLETELY
FICTIONAL TRANSCRIPT INTO THE
RECORD DURING AN OFFICIAL
HEARING.
THIS GUY LIES OVER AND OVER
AGAIN BECAUSE THE TRUTH DOES NOT
FIT WHAT IS A WARPED VENGEFUL,
RAGE INDUCED, PSYCHOTIC
ANTI-TRUMP NARRATIVE OF HIS.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
WE HAVE THE TRANSCRIPT.
WE DON'T NEED HEARSAY
WHISTLE-BLOWERS.
WE DON'T CARE WHAT HE DID WAS
WRONG, HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
HONEST ABOUT IT.
WE REALLY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
SHAM HEARINGS HE IS.
HE IS GOING TO COME OUT OF A
HEARING?
YOU DON'T LET REPUBLICANS IN,
HE'LL EAT WHAT IS FAVORABLE TO
YOU.
YOU WON'T LET REPUBLICANS SEE
THE ENTIRE TRANSCRIPT UNLESS
THEY WERE DEMOCRATIC STAFFER, A
MINDER.
THAT IS THEIR JOB.
THEY TOO HAVE A DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS.
THE PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY, THEY
SHOULD BE IN THE ROOM EVERY
SINGLE TIME.
THE PRESIDENT WAS FREELY AND
FAIRLY ELECTED AND THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE LANDSLIDE, EVER SINCE HE
HAS BEEN ELECTED HE HAS BEEN
FAITHFULLY EXECUTING HIS SWORN
DUTY TO THE CONSTITUTION AND TO
THE CONTRARY.
ONE OF THOSE SWORN DUTIES
DETAILED ARTICLE TWO, SECTION
THREE OF THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES THE
PRESIDENT UPHOLD THE LAWS OF THE
LAND.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE UKRAINE
ELECTION INTERFERENCE AND 2016.
I WOULD INCLUDE BIOTIN USING
TAXPAYER DOLLARS, 1 BILLION
TAXPAYING DOLLARS.
SHAKING DOWN UKRAINE TO GET A
PROSECUTOR FIRED WHO WE NOW KNOW
WAS INVESTIGATING HIS SON.
THE SAME SON WHO HAD NO
EXPERIENCE WITH GAS, ENERGY,
OIL, OR THE COUNTRY OF UKRAINE.
NO EXPERIENCE AND HE'S BEING
PAID MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
PROSECUTORS INVESTIGATING HIM,
HE SAYS YOU HAVE SIX HOURS.
CANNOT GET ANY MONEY UNLESS YOU
FIRE THAT PROSECUTOR.
WE NOW KNOW THAT WAS
INVESTIGATING HIS SON.
THAT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE THEY WERE
TRYING TO BUY FAVOR AND GOODWILL
FROM THE BIDENS.
WHY ON EARTH WOULD YOU PAY A
CANDIDATE NO EXPERIENCE, HE'S ON
A KID, HE'S 49 YEARS OLD,
WHY WOULD YOU PAY THE SUDDENLY
VICE PRESIDENT MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WHEN HE HAS ZERO
EXPERIENCE AND ANYTHING RELATED
TO UKRAINE OR ENERGY.
THIS WAS WHY IT'S SO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND REPUBLICANS
IN CONGRESS TO THEIR JOB.
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF ALL OF THIS
ON TOP OF WHAT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED AS THE SINGLE BIGGEST
ABUSE OF POWER, CORRUPTION
SCANDAL IN MODERN DAY HISTORY.
WE HAVE AN UPDATE.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT, WE
KNOW IT'S FINISHED, IT STILL NOT
BEEN RELEASED TO THE PUBLIC.
WE HAVE SEEN DELAY AFTER DELAY
AFTER DELAY.
WHY?
SENATOR GRASSLEY OF IOWA
TWEETED, "ALL OF THE DELAYS IN
THE EXCUSES, WHY THE IG REPORT
IS IN PUBLIC YET AFTER SEVERAL
MONTHS OF ANTICIPATION.
THAT LEADS ME TO BE SUSPICIOUS
IT'S GOING TO BE DEEP-SIXED BY
THE DEEP STATE."
TONIGHT, I DON'T KNOW IF THE
FINDINGS ARE NOT YET PUBLISHED
RATE M IS ANGRY AS ANYBODY ELSE.
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
WE KNOW THERE WAS PREMEDITATED
THOUGHT ON THE PFIZER REPORT.
WE KNOW THE BULK OF INFORMATION
WAS THE HILLARY CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR, DIRTY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER.
THEY CAN HELP HER GET ELECTED
AND 2016?
BY THE WAY, WHAT DID WE LEARN
FROM THAT?
THEY NEVER VERIFIED IT AND IT
WAS UNVERIFIABLE.
THAT WOULD MEAN THE DEEP STATE
IS PROTECTING THEIR OWN.
WE WILL FIND OUT, EVENTUALLY WE
NEED TO GET TO THE TRUTH.
NOW I'M TOLD THE FIRST WEEK
OF NOVEMBER.
I GUESS I SHOULDN'T HOLD MY
BREATH.
THANKFULLY INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER JOHN SOLOMON WILL JOIN
US IN A FEW MINUTES WITH
POSITIVE NEWS ABOUT THE FISA
REPORT.
HE HAS OTHER BREAKING DETAILS
ABOUT THE ORIGINS OF THE RUSSIA
WITCH HUNT AT THAT INVESTIGATION
IS BEING LED BY THE U.S.
ATTORNEY JOHN DURHAM.
IT'S NOW ONGOING AND IS NOW
EXPANDING IN SIZE AND SCOPE
BECAUSE OF NEW, EXPLOSIVE
EVIDENCE.
TONIGHT FOX NEWS IS REPORTING
THIS BRAND-NEW EVIDENCE GOES
UNCOVERED DURING A RECENT TRIP
TO ROME WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR.
HE WAS THERE.
HE HAS BEEN THERE.
KEEP IN MIND, THIS PROBE IS
FOCUSED ON WHETHER OR NOT THE
POWERFUL TOOLS OF OUR
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY WHERE
WEAPONIZED AGAINST YOU, WE, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND PEOPLE
ASSOCIATED WITH AN AFFILIATED
WITH THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WHETHER OR NOT INTEL OFFICIALS
AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL TO
CIRCUMVENT U.S. LAW WERE
OUTSOURCING SURVEILLANCE AGAINST
INNOCENT AMERICANS BY OTHER
COUNTRIES.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY'RE GETTING
THE INTEL COMMUNITY IN ITALY AND
AUSTRALIA AND GREAT BRITAIN TO
DO THINGS THEY COULDN'T DO
LEGALLY HERE.
OKAY.
THAT WOULD MAKE YOU GUILTY OF
CIRCUMVENTING THE LAWS.
BOTH COUNTRIES ARE NOW FULLY
COOPERATING WITH THE PROBE.
WE CAN REPORT THAT TONIGHT.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT FROM THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER," WE NOW
HAVE IDENTIFIED FOUR NOTORIOUS
DEEP STATE FIGURES, THERE
WRAPPED UP, UP TO THEIR EYEBALLS
AND THIS INVESTIGATION INCLUDING
OBAMA'S CHIEF JOHN BRENNAN.
OBAMA'S DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE, JAMES CLAPPER.
RETIRED FBI AGENT, PETER STRZOK.
ALSO, THE AUTHOR OF
HILLARY CLINTON'S DIRTY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER, CHRISTOPHER STEELE
HIMSELF.
THIS IS BIG NEWS TONIGHT.
NOW THE WALLS SEEM TO FINALLY BE
CAVING IN AND WE ARE GOING TO
GET TO THE TRUTH.
ONE OF THESE FOUR MEN, WHAT DO
THEY HAVE IN COMMON?
THEY ALL POSSESS A RAGE AND
PSYCHOTIC HATRED FOR ALL THINGS
DONALD TRUMP AND TWO, THEY
SHOULD ALL BE VERY, VERY NERVOUS
TONIGHT BECAUSE U.S. ATTORNEY
JOHN DURHAM, BILL BARR, THEY'RE
PUSHING TO ADD TO THE TRUTH.
ONE OTHER GOOD SIGN THAT DURHAM
AND HIS INVESTIGATION IS GAINING
SERIOUS TRACTION.
YOU HAVE HIS CURRENT COLLEAGUE
AT MSNBC, THAT WOULD BE AREA 51.
ROSS DWELLEY RACHEL MADDOW, MST
AND C, THEY'RE TRYING TO SPEND
THE UPCOMING FINDINGS.
THEY KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE BAD
WITH A BRAND-NEW CONSPIRACY
THEORY.
THEY WERE PEDDLING CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, LIES, PROPAGANDA,
MISINFORMATION, DAY AFTER DAY,
WEEK AFTER WEEK, MONTH AFTER
MONTH.
WENT ON FOR YEARS.
IN OTHER TRYING TO PREPARE
THEMSELVES FOR ONE THE REAL
TRUTH IS COMING OUT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE THEY'RE GOING
TO USE THE POWER OF THE U.S.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO HELP THEM
MAKE THAT CASE THAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE THE REAL SOURCE OF
THE SCANDAL HERE.
>> WITH WHAT THEY PRAY TO BE
DOING TO BOOST THE PRESIDENT'S
CAMPAIGN, THEIR CROSSING A BIT
OF A RUBICON IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT IS FOR.
PART OF WHAT WE WILL HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT WHEN THIS IS OVER IS
HOW WE CROSSED BACK OVER IT.
>> Sean: NOW AFTER TWO YEARS,
THEY ARE BACK AT IT.
MORE CONSPIRACY THEORIES, MORE
LIES, MORE SPECULATION, ZERO
FACTS.
THERE YOU HAVE IT.
AREA 51, THEY'RE AT IT AGAIN.
WHAT WILL THEY LEARN?
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT LEARNING
BRING FOR THEM IT'S AN AGENDA.
THAT'S ABOUT ALL DEMOCRAT.
IT'S ABOUT -- GET RID OF TRUMP
ANYWAY WE CAN.
TRUTH?
THAT DOESN'T MATTER TO HER OR
ANYBODY ELSE FRANKLY ON THAT
NETWORK.
SOMEONE MIGHT WANT TO REMIND
NBC'S CHIEF CONSPIRACY THEORIST,
THAT U.S. ATTORNEY JOHN DURHAM
IS AN INVESTIGATOR, LONG
RESPECTED BY BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE.
IN FACT HE WAS PREVIOUSLY
APPOINTED BY TWO DEMOCRATIC
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO INVESTIGATE
HIGHLY SENSITIVE CASES.
REMEMBER JANET RENO?
SHE SELECTED HIM TO INVESTIGATE
CORRUPT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS AND THEIR DEALINGS
WITH NOTORIOUS GANGSTER "WHITEY"
BULGER.
ERIC HOLDER, HE APPOINTED HIM
HIMSELF TO LEAVE THE GEO
HIMSELF TO LEAVE THE DEO
HIMSELF TO LEAVE THE DOJ INTO
ENHANCED INTERROGATION
TECHNIQUES.
THE ONGOING INVESTIGATION INTO
THE ORIGINS OF THE WITCH HUNT IS
NOT A POLITICAL STUNT.
IT'S A VERY REAL PROBE ABOUT
REAL ABUSES OF POWER.
WHAT HAPPENED AND 2016 AND
BEYOND?
IF THIS CONTINUES TO HAPPEN, YOU
DON'T HAVE A CONSTITUTION.
YOU DON'T HAVE A RULE OF LAW.
YOU DON'T HAVE EQUAL
APPLICATION.
THERE'S GOT TO BE A RECKONING
ANY DEEP STATE.
BUT THEY KEEP DOING THIS THEY
WILL GET YOU SIX WAYS, BUT
SUNDAY.
WERE GOING TO LOSE THOSE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTIONS THAT
WE THOUGHT WE HAD IN THIS
COUNTRY.
ALSO BREAKING TONIGHT,
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER JOHN
SOLOMON.
HE IS PRONE TO EVIDENCE THAT
JAMES COMEY'S FBI KNEW THE DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER WAS GARBAGE.
THEY KNEW IT.
THEY USED IT ANYWAY TO WILLFULLY
DEFRAUD A FISA COURT AND OBTAIN
THE WORLD.
TO SPY ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATE BY THE NAME OF
CARTER PAGE WHICH GIVE THEM A